[Music]
here we have all the amenities
pool
target range river with loads of fish
here we are good to see you paul you
look well dad i stay busy
we gotta talk
what is this place dad
it's complicated
were those gunshots where is he
yes
get to the fortress i'm leaving what's
the fortress
it's our emergency shelter
who are they frederick balzari
what does he want
me
you know i should go help my dad he
probably doesn't know how to use that
thing
[Music]
i have a serious grievance with you and
your government it's your government too
i will be knocking on your door there's
sitting ducks out there
they're here go
i'm that kind of dad i guess
are you strong
i'm on my way he's a notorious criminal
that we've been tracking for years
how many people must die i'm not leaving
here without my father neither am i
[Music]
no one leaves this mountain
i should have killed you shoulda woulda
coulda anybody home any last words
all transactions are final
you coming i'm having fun
[Music]
you